most of our post-brexit future and as a
science superpower we know they want to
reinvigorate the city of london we know
that they want to give additional help
to scientific and organizations that
will come up with new discoveries to
give britain new meaning post-brexit and
he also said that britain's plan for
growth would focus on innovation skills
and
infrastructure okay just a reminder that
uh four budget statements it's the chair
of ways and means uh who changed the
session not the speaker
let's go over to the chancellorshi neck
i announced our initial response to
coronavirus
what was originally thought to be a
temporary disruption to our way of life
has fundamentally altered it people
are still being told to stay in their
homes
businesses have been ordered to close
thousands of people are in hospital
much has changed but one thing
has stayed the same i
said i would do whatever it takes
i have done and i will do so yeah
[Music]
we have announced over 208 billion
pounds of support
protecting jobs keeping businesses
afloat
helping families get by
despite this unprecedented response the
damage
coronavirus has done to our economy
has been acute since march
over seven hundred thousand people have
lost their jobs
our economy has shrunk by ten percent
the largest fall in over 300 years
our borrowing is the highest it has been
outside
of wartime it's going to take this
country
and the whole world a long time to
recover
from this extraordinary economic
situation
but we will recover
this budget meets the moment with a
three-part plan
to protect the jobs and livelihoods of
the british people
first we will continue doing whatever it
takes
to support the british people and
businesses
through this moment of crisis
second once we are on the way to
recovery
we will need to begin fixing the public
finances
and i want to be honest today about our
plans
to do that and third in today's budget
we begin the work of building our future
economy madam deputy speaker
today's forecasts show that our response
to coronavirus
is working the prime minister last week
set out
our cautious but irreversible road map
to ease restrictions
whilst protecting the british people
the nhs deserving of immense praise
has had extraordinary success in
vaccinating more than 20 million people
across the united kingdom and combined
with our economic response
one of the most comprehensive and
generous in the world
this means the office for budget
responsibility
are now forecasting in their words a
swifter
and more sustained recovery than they
expected
in november the obr now expect
the economy to return to its pre-covered
level
by the middle of next year six months
earlier
than previously thought that means
growth is faster
unemployment lower wages higher
investment higher
household incomes higher
but while our prospects are now stronger
coronavirus has done
and is still doing profound damage
and today's forecast make clear
repairing the long-term damage
will take time the obr still expect
that in five years time because of
coronavirus
our economy will be three percent
smaller
than it would have been before i share
the detail of the obr's forecast
let me thank richard hughes and his team
for their work
the obr forecast that our economy will
grow this year
by four percent by 7.3 percent
in 2022 then 1.7
1.6 and 1.7 in the last three years
of the forecast and the obr have said
that our interventions to support jobs
have worked in july last year
they expected unemployment to peak at
11.9 percent
today because of our interventions
they forecast a much lower peak six
and a half percent that means
1.8 million fewer people
are expected to be out of work than
previously thought
every job lost is a tragedy which is why
protecting
creating and supporting jobs remains
my highest priority
so madam deputy speaker let me turn
straight away
to the first part of this budget's plan
to protect the jobs and livelihoods of
the british people
through the remaining phase of this
crisis
first the furlough scheme will be
extended
until the end of september for employees
there will be no change to the terms
they will continue to receive
80 of their salary for hours not worked
until the scheme ends as businesses
reopen
we will ask them to contribute alongside
the taxpayer
to the cost of paying their employees
nothing will change
until july when we will ask for a small
contribution
of just 10 percent and 20 in august
and september the government is proud
of the furlough one of the most generous
schemes in the world
effectively protecting millions of
people's jobs
and incomes second
support for the self-employed will also
continue
until september with a fourth grant
covering the period february to april
and a fifth and final grant
from may onwards the fourth grant will
provide
three months of support at eighty
percent of average trading profits
for the fifth grant people will continue
to receive grants
worth three months of average profits
with the system
open for claims from late july
but as the economy reopens over the
summer
it is fair to target our support
towards those most affected by the
pandemic
so people whose turnover has fallen by
30
or more will continue to receive the
full
80 percent grant people whose turnover
has fallen by less than 30 percent
will therefore have less need of
taxpayer support
and will receive a 30 grand
and i can also announce a major
improvement in access
to the self-employed scheme when the
scheme was launched
the newly self-employed couldn't qualify
because they hadn't all
filed the 1920 tax return
but as the tax return deadline has now
passed
i can announce today that provided they
filed a tax return by midnight last
night
over 600 000 more people
many of whom became self-employed last
year
can now claim the fourth and fifth
grants
over the course of this crisis we will
have spent
33 billion pounds supporting the
self-employed
one of the most generous programs for
self-employed people
anywhere in the world third
we're also extending our support for the
lowest paid
and most vulnerable to support
low-income households
the universal credit uplift of 20 pounds
a week
will continue for a further six months
well beyond the end of this national
lockdown
we'll provide working tax credit
claimants with equivalent support
for the next six months and because of
the way that system works operationally
we will need to do so with a one-off
payment of 500 pounds
and over the course of this year as the
economy begins to recover
we are shifting our resources and focus
towards getting people into decent
well-paid jobs
we reaffirm our commitment to end low
pay
increasing the national living wage to
eight pounds 91
from april an annual pay rise of almost
350 pounds
for someone working full time on the
national living wage
and my right honourable friends the
education secretary and the work and
pension secretary
are taking action to give people the
skills they need
to get jobs or get better jobs the
restart program
supporting over a million long-term
unemployed people
the number of work coaches doubled the
kickstart scheme
funding high quality jobs for over a
quarter of a million young people
the prime minister's lifetime skills
guarantee giving
every adult the opportunity for a fully
funded level three qualification
and we want businesses to hire new
apprentices
so we're paying them more to do it today
i am doubling the incentive payments we
give businesses
to 3 000 pounds that's for all
new apprentice hires of any age
alongside investing 126 million pounds
of new money to triple the number of
traineeships we're taking what works to
get people into jobs
and making it better
[Music]
madam deputy speaker one of the hidden
tragedies
of lockdown has been the increase in
domestic abuse
so i'm announcing today an extra 19
million pounds
on top of the 125 million pounds we
announced
the spending review for domestic
violence programs
to reduce the risk of reoffending and to
pilot
a network of respite runs to provide
specialist support
for vulnerable homeless women to
recognize the sacrifices made by so many
women and men in the armed forces
community
i'm providing an additional 10 million
pounds to support veterans
with mental health needs and on current
plans
the funding to support survivors of the
thalidomide scandal
runs out in 2023.
they deserve better than to have
constant uncertainty
about the future costs of their care
so not only will i extend this funding
with an initial down payment
of around 40 million pounds i am today
announcing a lifetime commitment
guaranteeing funding forever and let me
thank
the thalidomide trust and the honourable
member for north dorset
for their leadership on this important
issue
as well as supporting people's jobs
incomes
the lowest paid and most vulnerable
this budget also protects businesses
we've been providing businesses with
direct cash grants
through the recent restrictions these
grants come to an end
in march i can announce today that we
will provide
a new restart grant in april to help
businesses reopen and get going again
non-essential retail businesses will
open first so they will receive grants
of up to six thousand pounds per
premises
hospitality and leisure businesses
including
personal care and gyms will open later
or be more impacted by restrictions when
they do
so we'll give them grants of up to
eighteen thousand
pounds that's five billion pounds of
new grants on top of the twenty billion
pounds we've already provided
taking our direct total cash support to
business
to 25 billion pounds
and i pay tribute to my right honourable
friend the member for romney and
southampton north
for highlighting the particular needs of
the personal care sector
and with my right-hand friend the
culture secretary
we're making available 700 million
pounds
to support our incredible arts culture
and sporting institutions as they reopen
backing the uk and ireland's joint 2030
world cup bid
launching a new approach to
apprenticeships in the creative
industries
and extending our 500 million pound
film and tv production restart scheme
even with the new restart grants some
businesses
will also need loans to see them through
as the bounce back loan and see bills
programs come to an end
we're introducing a new recovery loan
scheme
to take their place businesses of
any size can apply for loans from 25 000
pounds
up to 10 million pounds through to the
end of this year
and the government will provide a
guarantee to lenders
of 80 percent
last year we provided an unprecedented
100 business rates holiday in england
for all eligible businesses in the
retail
hospitality and leisure sectors a tax
cut
worth 10 billion pounds
this year we'll continue with the 100
business rates holiday for the first
three months of the year
in other words through to the end of
june
for the remaining nine months of the
year business rates will
still be discounted by two thirds
up to a value of two million pounds for
closed businesses
with a lower cap for those who have been
able to stay open
a six billion pound tax cut for business
one of the hardest hit sectors has been
hospitality
and tourism 150
000 businesses that employ over 2.4
million people
need our support to protect
those jobs i can confirm that the 5
reduced rate of vat will be extended
for 6 months to the 30th of september
[Music]
and even then we won't go straight back
to the twenty percent rate we'll have an
interim rate of twelve and a half
percent
for another six months not returning to
the standard rate until
april of next year in total
we're cutting that next year by almost
five
billion pounds madam deputy speaker
the housing sector supports over half a
million jobs
the cut and stamp duty i announced last
summer has helped
hundreds of thousands of people buy a
home and supported the economy
at a critical time but due to the sheer
volume of transactions we're seeing many
new purchases
won't complete in time for the end of
march
so i can announce today the 500 000
pound
nil rape band will not end on the 31st
of march
it will end on the 30th of june
then to smooth the transition back to
normal
the nil rate band will be 250 000 pounds
double its standard level until the end
of september
and we will only return to the usual
level of 125
000 pounds from october the first
even with the stamp duty cut there is
still a significant barrier
to people getting on the housing ladder
the cost
of a deposit so i'm announcing today a
new policy
to stand behind home buyers a mortgage
guarantee lenders who provide mortgages
to home buyers
who can only afford a 5 deposit
will benefit from a government guarantee
on those mortgages
and i'm pleased to say that several of
the country's largest lenders
including lloyds natwest santander
barclays and hsbc
will be offering these 95 mortgages
from next month and i know more
including virgin money
will follow shortly after a policy that
gives people
who can can't afford a big deposit the
chance to buy their own home
as the prime minister has said we want
to turn generation
rent into generation buy
so madam deputy speaker the furlough
extended to september self-employed
grants
extended to september universal credit
uplift
extended to september more money
to tackle domestic violence bigger
incentives
to hire apprentices hire grants to
struggling businesses
extra funds for culture arts and sport
new loan schemes
to finance businesses kickstart restart
a lifetime skills guarantee business
rates
cut vat cut stamp duty
cut and a new mortgage guarantee the
first part of a budget
that protects the jobs and livelihoods
of the british people
[Music]
and madam deputy speaker as you can see
we're going long extending our support
well beyond the end of the road map
to accommodate even the most cautious
view about the time
it might take to exit the restrictions
let me summarize for the house the scale
of our total fiscal response to
coronavirus
at this budget we are announcing an
additional
65 billion pounds of measures over this
year and next
to support the economy in response to
coronavirus
taking into account the significant
support announced at the spending review
this means our total covert support
package
this year and next is 352
billion pounds and once you include
the measures announced at spring budget
last year including
the step change in capital investment
total fiscal support from this
government
over this year and next amounts to 407
billion pounds coronavirus
has caused one of the largest
most comprehensive and sustained
economic shocks
this country has ever faced and by
any objective analysis this government
has delivered
one of the largest most comprehensive
and sustained responses
this country has ever seen
so madam deputy speaker we're using the
full
measure of our fiscal firepower to
protect the jobs
and livelihoods of the british people
but the damage done by coronavirus
combined with a level of support
unimaginable only 12 months ago
has created huge challenges for our
public finances
the obr's fiscal forecasts show that
this year
we have borrowed a record amount
355 billion pounds
that's 17 of our national income
the highest level of borrowing since
world war ii
next year as we continue our
unprecedented response to this crisis
borrowing is forecast to be 234 billion
pounds
10.3 percent of gdp an amount so
large it has only one rival in recent
history
this year without corrective action
borrowing would continue at very high
levels
leaving underlying debt rising
indefinitely
instead because of the steps i am taking
today
borrowing falls to four and a half
percent
of gdp in 2223
3.5 in 2324
then 2.9 and 2.8 percent
in the following two years and while
underlying debt
rises from 88.8 of gdp this year
to 93.8 next year
it then peaks at 97.1
in 2324 before stabilizing
and falling slightly to 97
and 96.8 in the final
two years of the forecast let me explain
why this matters the amount we've
borrowed
is comparable only with the amount we
borrowed during the two
world wars it's going to be the work
of many governments over many decades
to pay it back just as it would be
irresponsible to withdraw support too
soon it would also be irresponsible to
allow our future borrowing and debt to
rise
unchecked when crises come
we need to be able to act
and we need the fiscal freedom to act
a freedom that you only have if you
start with public finances in a good and
strong
place the only reason we have been able
to respond as boldly as we have to covid
is because 10 years of conservative
governments painstakingly
rebuilt our fiscal resilience
when the next crisis comes we need to be
able to act
again and while our borrowing costs
are affordable right now interest rates
and inflation may not stay low forever
and just a one percentage point increase
in both
would now cost us over 25 billion
pounds and as we have seen in the
markets
over the last few weeks sovereign bond
yields
can rise sharply
this budget is not the time to set
detailed fiscal rules
with precise targets and dates to
achieve them by
i don't believe that would be sensible
but i do want to be honest about what i
mean
by sustainable public finances and how
i plan to achieve them our fiscal
decisions
are guided by three principles
first while it is right to help
people and businesses through an acute
crisis like this one
in normal times the state should not be
borrowing
to pay for everyday public spending
second over the medium term we cannot
allow
our debt to keep rising and given how
high
our debt now is we need to pay close
attention
to its affordability and third
it is sensible to take advantage
of lower interest rates to invest in
capital projects
that can drive our future growth
so the question is how we achieve that
how we balance the extraordinary support
we are providing to the economy right
now
with the need to begin the work of
fixing our public finances
i have and always will be honest with
the country about the challenges
we face so i'm announcing today
two measures to begin that work
let me take each in turn
madam deputy speaker
response to coronavirus has been fair
with the poorest households benefiting
the most from our interventions
and our approach to fixing the public
finances
will be fair too asking more of those
people and businesses who can afford to
contribute
and protecting those who cannot
so this government is not going to raise
the rates of
income tax national insurance or v.a.t
instead our first step is to freeze
personal tax thresholds we've nearly
doubled
the income tax personal allowance over
the last decade
making it the most generous of any g20
country
we will of course deliver our promise to
increase it again
next year to twelve thousand five
hundred and seventy pounds
but we will then keep it at this more
generous level
until april 2026 the higher rate
threshold
will similarly be increased next year to
50 000 pounds 270
and will then also remain at that level
for the same period
nobody's take home pay will be less than
it is now
as a result of this policy but i want to
be clear
with all members that this policy does
remove
the incremental benefit created had
thresholds continued
to increase with inflation we are not
hiding it
i am here explaining it to the house and
it is in the budget document
in black and white it is a
tax policy that is progressive and fair
and i will also maintain at their
current levels until april 2026
the inheritance tax thresholds the
pensions lifetime allowance
the annual exempt amount in capital
gains tax and for two years from april
2022
the vat registration threshold which at
85 000 pounds
will remain more than twice as generous
as the eu
and oecd averages we'll also tackle
fraud and our covert schemes
with a hundred million pounds to set up
a new hmrc
task force of around a thousand
investigators
as well as new measures and new
investment in hmrc
to clamp down on tax avoidance and
evasion the full details are set out in
the red book
madam deputy speaker the government is
providing businesses
with over a hundred billion pounds of
support
to get through this pandemic so it is
fair
and necessary to ask them to contribute
to our recovery
so the second step i am taking today
is that in 2023 the rate of corporation
tax
paid on company profits will increase
to 25 even
after this change the united kingdom
will still have the lowest
corporation tax rate in the g7
lower than the united states canada
italy japan germany and france
we're also introducing some crucial
protections first this new higher rate
won't take effect until april 2023
well after the point when the obr expect
the economy
to have recovered and even then
because corporation tax is only charged
on company profits
any struggling business will by
definition
be unaffected second
i'm protecting small businesses with
profits of fifty thousand pounds or less
by creating a small profits rate
maintained at the current rate
of nineteen percent this means
around 70 of companies
1.4 million businesses will be
completely
unaffected and third
we will introduce a taper above 50 000
so that only businesses with profits of
a quarter of a million pounds or greater
will be taxed at the full 25 percent
rate
that means only 10 percent of companies
will pay the full higher rate
so yes it's a tax rise on company
profits
but only on the larger more profitable
companies
and only in two years time
and i wanted to announce this now
because i think
for business certainty matters
for the next two years i'm also
making the tax treatment of losses
significantly
more generous by allowing businesses to
carry back losses of up to two million
pounds
for three years providing a significant
cash flow benefit
this means companies can now claim
additional tax refunds
of up to seven hundred and sixty
thousand pounds
and because of the current eight percent
bank surcharge
the implied overall tax rate for banks
would be too high
so we will review the surcharge to make
sure the combined rate of tax on the uk
banking sector
doesn't increase significantly from its
current level
and to make sure this important industry
remains internationally
competitive madam deputy speaker
these are significant decisions to have
taken
decisions no chancellor wants to make
i recognize they might not be popular
but they are honest and let's consider
the alternatives the first
is to do nothing to leave our deficit
problem untreated
our debt problem for someone else in the
future to deal with
that has never been the way of a
conservative government
and nor do i believe it can be the way
of a responsible chancellor
another alternative would be to try and
find all the savings we need
from public spending but when we said
at the last election that we were the
party of public services people believed
us
and they were right to believe us and
when we said we'd be the party that
invests in new infrastructure they were
right to believe that too
the only other alternative would be to
increase the rates of tax
on working people but i don't believe
that
would be right either so i believe
our approach while bold is compatible
with our duty as a fiscally responsible
and business friendly government this is
the right choice and i am confident it
will command
public assent i have one
final announcement on business tax with
the lowest corporation tax in the g7
and a new small profits rate the uk will
have
a pro business tax regime
but we need to do even more to encourage
businesses to invest right now
business investment creates jobs lifts
growth
spurs innovation and drives productivity
for decades we've lagged behind our
international peers
right now while many businesses are
struggling
others have been able to build up
significant cash reserves
we need to unlock that investment we
need an investment led
recovery so today i can announce
the super deduction for the next two
years
when companies invest they can reduce
their tax bill
not just by a proportion of the cost of
that investment as they do now
or even by a hundred percent of their
cost
the so-called full expensing that some
have called for
with the super deduction they can now
reduce their tax bill
by 130 percent of the cost
let me give the house an example under
the existing rules a construction firm
buying 10 million pounds of new
equipment could reduce their taxable
income
in the year they invest by just 2.6
million pounds
with the super deduction they can now
reduce it
by 13 million pounds
we've never tried this before in our
country
the obr have said it will boost business
investment by
10 around 20 billion pounds more
per year it meets at makes our tax
regime for business investment truly
world leading lifting us from 30th in
the oecd
to first and and
worth 25 billion pounds during the two
years it is in place
this will be the biggest business tax
cut in modern
british history bold
unprecedented action to get companies
investing
creating jobs and driving our economic
recovery madam deputy speaker
let me now turn to duties this is a
tough time
for hospitality so i can confirm
that the planned increases in duties for
spirits like scotch whiskey
wine cider and beer
will all be cancelled all
alcohol duties frozen for the second
year in a row
only the third time in two decades
and right now to keep the cost of living
low
i'm not prepared to increase the cost of
a tank of fuel
so the planned increase in fuel duty is
also
[Music]
cancelled
madam deputy speaker this budget
protects the jobs and livelihoods of the
british people
this budget is honest about the
challenges facing our public finances
and how we will begin to fix them
and this budget does one other thing
it lays the foundations of our future
economy the third part of our plan
if we want a better future economy we
have to make it
happen we have to do things that have
never been done before
the world is not going to be any less
competitive after coronavirus
so it's not enough to have some general
desire
to grow the economy we need a real
commitment to green
growth it's not enough to have some
general desire
to increase productivity we need a real
commitment
to give every business large or small
the opportunity to grow
innovate and succeed it's not enough to
have a general desire to create jobs
we need a real commitment to create jobs
where people are
and change the economic geography of
this country
and we can't strengthen our domestic
economy
without remaining a global
outward-looking nation
this future economy won't be created in
any one budget
but today we lay the foundations
madam deputy speaker our future economy
needs investment in green industries
across the united kingdom
so i can announce today the first ever
uk
infrastructure bank located in leeds
the bank will invest across the uk in
public and private projects
to finance the green industrial
revolution
beginning this spring it will have an
initial capitalization of 12
billion pounds and we expect it to
support at least
40 billion pounds of total investment in
infrastructure
and i know my right honourable friend
the member for pudsey will particularly
welcome the location
of this new institution offshore wind is
an innovative industry
where the uk already has a global
competitive advantage
so we're funding new port infrastructure
to build the next generation of offshore
wind projects in t
side and humberside and in november i
announced we would launch a world
leading sovereign green bond
today we're going further announcing a
new
retail savings product to give all uk
savers the chance
to support green projects as my right on
the friend the member for north
east bedfordshire has campaigned for
we've also asked dame clara first to
establish a new group
to position the city as the global
leader for voluntary
high quality carbon offset markets and
underpinning
all of this will be an updated monetary
policy remit for the bank of england
it reaffirms their 2 target but now
it will also reflect the importance of
environmental sustainability
and the transition to net zero madam
deputy speaker our future economy
will also address our productivity
problem and support small business
too often smaller firms don't have the
time or resources
to acquire the extra skills and training
they need to be more efficient
more digital and more productive thanks
to be the business
we have made a good start at supporting
these firms
today the business secretary and i are
going further
with a new set of uk-wide schemes
help to grow first help to grow
management will help tens of thousands
of small
and medium-sized businesses get
world-class management training
dozens of business schools across the uk
will offer a new
executive development program with
mentoring
and peer learning and government will
contribute
90 of the cost a real commitment
to learn more make more and earn more
second help to grow digital with the
pandemic
many businesses have moved online this
has been
a challenge but we want to turn it into
an opportunity
we're going to help small businesses
develop digital skills
by giving them free expert training and
a 50
discount on new productivity enhancing
software
worth up to 5 000 pounds each
both programs will commence by the
autumn and i'd urge
interested businesses to register today
on gov
dot uk forward slash help to grow
a real commitment to help over a hundred
thousand businesses
become more innovative more competitive
and more profitable
madam deputy speaker a future economy
requires us to be at the forefront
of the next scientific and technological
revolutions
becoming a scientific superpower is
something
we can be i don't think that's hubristic
or unrealistic our incredible
vaccination program
has shown the world what this country is
capable of
so i'm providing an extra 1.6 billion
pounds today
to continue the roll out and improve our
future preparedness
and i want to make the uk the best place
in the world for high growth innovative
companies
so i'm launching two wide ranging
consultations today
to make sure our research and
development tax reliefs
and our enterprise management incentives
are internationally
competitive and my right honourable
friend the home secretary
knows that a scientific superpower needs
scientific
superstars so together we're announcing
ambitious visa reforms
aimed at highly skilled migrants
including
a new unsponsored points-based visa to
attract the best and most promising
international talent in science research
and tech
new improved visa processes for
scale-ups and entrepreneurs
and radically simplified bureaucracy for
high-skill visa applications
now as well as support for innovation
and access to talent
high growth firms need access to capital
to do that we're taking steps to give
the pensions industry more flexibility
to unlock billions of pounds from
pension funds
into innovative new ventures launching a
new future fund breakthrough
to help fill the scale-up funding gap
and
changing the rules to encourage more
countries more companies
to list here let me thank lord hill
for leading this landmark review the fca
will be consulting on his proposals
very shortly
madam deputy speaker our future economy
depends on remaining a united kingdom
millions of families and businesses in
scotland
wales and northern ireland have
contributed to
and benefited from our coronavirus
response
and central to that has been a treasury
that acts for the whole united kingdom
that's not a political point it's an
undeniable
truth the majority of today's budget
measures
will apply directly to people in all
four nations
of the united kingdom and i'm taking
further specific steps
with three accelerated scottish city and
growth deals
in airship argh island butte and folker
three more in north wales mid wales and
swansea bay
and funding for the holly head hydrogen
hub
the global center of rail excellence in
neathport tolbert
the aberdeen energy transition zone as
well as the global
underwater hub and north sea transition
deal
along with the first allocations of the
400 million
new deal for northern ireland and
through the barnet formula
the decisions i'm taking in this budget
also increased the funding
for the devolved administrations by 1.2
billion pounds
in scotland 740 million pounds
in wales and 410 million pounds
for the northern ireland executive
and madam deputy speaker our future
economy
demands a different economic geography
if we are serious about wanting to level
up
that starts with the institutions of
economic power
few institutions are more powerful
than the one i am enormously privileged
to lead
the treasury along with the other
critical
economic departments including bays dit
and mhclg we will establish a
new economic campus in darlington
and i know my honorable friend the
member for darlington
will particularly welcome this
announcement
redrawing our economic map means
rebalancing our economic investment
i have already revised the treasury's
green book
and set out the highest sustained levels
of public investment across the uk
since the 1970s but we can go further
i am announcing today over a billion
pounds
for 45 new towns deals
from castleford to clay cross rochdale
to rowley regis
and whitby to wolverhampton and let me
pay tribute
to local leaders like the brilliant
mayor for the west midlands andy street
who are making the case for investment
in their area
we're also creating 150 million pound
fund
to help communities across the uk take
ownership
of pubs theaters shops or local sports
clubs at loss of
risk of loss putting more power in the
hands
of local people and i'm launching the
first round
of the leveling up fund today inviting
applications
from local areas across the united
kingdom
and i'm grateful to my right honourable
friends the transport secretary
and the community secretary for their
support on this crucial
initiative
madam deputy speaker i have one final
announcement
that exemplifies the future economy
a policy on a scale we've never done
before
a policy to bring investment trade and
most importantly
jobs right across this country
to replace the industries of the past
with green
innovative fast-growing new businesses
to encourage free trade and reinforce
our position as an
outward-looking trading nation open to
the world
a policy we can now only pursue now that
we are out
of the european union freeports
freeports are special economic zones
with different rules to make it easier
and cheaper
to do business they're well established
internationally
but we're taking a unique approach our
freeports
will have simpler planning to allow
businesses to build
infrastructure funding to improve
transport links
cheaper customs with favorable tariffs
vat
or duties and lower taxes with tax
breaks to encourage
construction private investment and job
creation
an unprecedented economic boost across
the united kingdom freeports will be a
truly
uk-wide policy and we will work
constructively
with the scottish welsh and northern
irish administrations
today i can announce the eight freeport
locations
in england east midlands airport
felix doe and harrich humber
liverpool city region plymouth
solent thames and t side
eight new free ports in eight english
regions
unlocking billions of pounds of private
sector investment generating trade
and jobs up and down the country
i commend members from across the house
for their campaigning
but in particular the honorable members
for red car
clee thoughts and great grimsby as well
as inspiring local leaders like ben
houchin the mayor
for teas valley madam deputy speaker
let's take just one of those places
t-side
in the past it was known for its success
in industries like steel now
when i look to the future of t-side i
see old industrial sites being used to
capture and store carbon
vaccines being manufactured offshore
wind turbines
creating clean energy for the rest of
the country all
located within a free port with a
treasury just down the road and the uk
infrastructure bank
only an hour away i see innovative
fast-growing businesses
hiring local people into decent
well-paid green jobs
i see people designing manufacturing and
exporting incredible new products and
services
i see people putting down roots in
places they are
proud to call home i see a people
optimistic and ambitious for their
future
that madam deputy speaker is the future
economy of this country
and so whilst this last year
has been a test unlike any other
that which we are we are
the fundamentals of our character as a
people
have not changed still determined
still generous still fair
that's what got us through the last year
it's what will
guide us through the next decade and
beyond
this time last year we set out to
deliver
on the promises we made to the british
people but the most important promise
was implicit and in truth is made by
every government
irrespective of their politics and that
is to do what must be done
when the danger is imminent and when no
one else can
today we set out a plan to protect
the jobs and livelihoods of the british
people
but the promises that underpin that plan
remain
unchanged from those we pledged
ourselves to
12 long months ago
to unite and lead to level
up to create a world-class education
system
to keep our streets safe to keep our nhs
strong to support the most vulnerable to
reform and improve public services
to grow the economy to spread prosperity
to extend the awesome power of
opportunity to
all corners of the united kingdom and
yes
to be honest and fair in all
that we do madam deputy speaker
an important moment is upon us a moment
of challenge
and of change of difficulties yes
but of possibilities too this
is a budget that meets that moment and i
commend it
to the house
i thank the chancellor of the exchequer
for his
budget statement and just before i call
the leader of the opposition there
so uh the chance of the exchequer there
laying out his budget they now go
through
some technical measures in the house of
commons let's take a closer look
at those measures the chancellor will
extend the furlough scheme
which has protected around 11 million
workers so far until the end of
september
the universal credit uplift of 20 pounds
per week will continue for a further six
months something rishi sunak initially
resisted
minimum wage will increase to eight
pounds 91
and are from april the stamp duty
holiday on
property sales is extended until the
30th of june
the business rates holiday for the
retail hospitality and leisure sectors
will continue until the end
of june and personal tax thresholds will
be frozen
from next year until 2026 that's into
the next parliament
so take home pay in cash terms that will
not fall
uh all alcohol duties will be frozen for
the second year in a row
and the planned increase in fuel duty
has also been cancelled the chancellor
said
corporation tax will rise from 19
to 25 percent from 2023 a big reversal
on george osborne and david cameron's
policies
the question is that income tax is
charged for the tax year
2021-22 and it is declared that it is
expedient
in the public interest that this
resolution should have statutory effect
well let's get
uh the thoughts now of our deputy
political editor sam coates sam
so rishi sunak today spent a huge amount
of money this was a 65 billion pound
uh budget uh he said that sorry to
interrupt sam will go over now to
kierstama
opposite the person actually making
decisions in this government
the trouble is the trouble is
it's those decisions that have left us
with the mess we find today
the worst economic crisis of any major
economy in the last 12 months
unemployment at five percent and as the
chancellor said forecast to rise
to six point five percent the debtor
over
two trillion i'm sure this budget will
look better on instagram
in fact this week's pr video
cost attachments so much i was half
expecting to see a line
in the obr forecast for it
but even the chancellor's film crew will
struggle to put a positive spin on this
after the decisions of the last year and
the decade of neglect
we needed a budget to fix the
foundations of our economy
to reward our key workers to protect the
nhs
and to build a more secure and
prosperous economy for the future
instead what we got was a budget that
papered over the cracks
rather than rebuilding the foundations a
budget that shows the government doesn't
understand
what went wrong in the last decade or
what's needed
in the next the chancellor may think
the chance may think that this is time
for a victory lap
but i'm afraid this budget won't feel so
good
for the millions of key workers who are
having their pay frozen
for the businesses swamped by debt
and the families paying more in council
tax
and the millions of people who are out
of work
or worried about losing their job and
although the chancellor spoke for almost
an hour we heard nothing
about a long-term plan to fix social
care
the chancellor may have forgotten about
it but the labour party
never will the british
people will rightly ask why has britain
why has britain suffered a worse
economic crisis than any major economy
the answer is staring us in the face
first the chancellor's decisions in the
last year this is the chancellor
who who blocked a circuit break in
september
ignoring the science he told the british
people
to live with coronavirus and live
without fear
a few weeks later we were forced into an
even longer and more
painful lockdown whatever spin the
chancellor tries to put on the figures
today
as a result of his decisions we've
suffered
deeper economic damage and much worse
outcomes
a madam deputy speaker that is nothing
compared with the decade
of political choices that meant that
britain went into this crisis
with nico with an economy built on
insecurity and inequality the chancellor
referred
to the last 10 years we've got an
economy as a result of those 10 years
with 3.6 million people in insecure work
where wages stagnated for a decade
over 4 million children living in
poverty
and critically we went into this crisis
with a hundred thousand unfilled posts
in the nhs
and where social care was ignored and
underfunded for a decade
members opposite voted for all of that
today's budget doesn't even recognize
that let alone
rectify it it's clear the chancellor is
now betting on a recovery fueled by a
consumer spending blitz
in fairness in fairness if my next door
neighbor
was spending tens of thousands of pounds
redecorating their flat i'd probably do
the same
but the central problem in our economy
is a deep-rooted
insecurity and inequality and this
budget
isn't the answer to that the chancellor
barely mentioned
inequality let alone tried to address it
so rather than the big transformative
budget we needed
this budget simply papers over the
cracks
if this had been a budget for the long
term it would have had a plan
a plan to protect our nhs a plan to fix
social care
and i can tell you this the labor budget
would have had the nhs and care homes
front and center but this budget
is almost silent on those questions
if this had been a budget to rebuild the
foundations
it would have fixed our broken social
security system
instead the chancellor has been dragged
kicking and streaming
to extend the 20-pound uplift in
universal
credit but only for a few months once
again
deferring the problem as a result
insecurity
and the threat of use of losing a
thousand pounds a year still hang over
six million families
they ask what we had to what we would do
we would keep the uplift until a new
fairer system could be put in place
if this budget if this budget was
serious
about rebuilding our shattered economy
it would have included a credible plan
to tackle unemployment
the chancellor said very little about
the kickstart scheme
no doubt because no doubt because
the prime minister says rubbish that's
no doubt because the kickstart scheme is
only helping one in a hundred eligible
young people
rubbish is the right word prime minister
in six months in six months it supported
just
twenty two thousand young people yet
youth unemployment is set to reach
1 million like so much of this budget
the chancellor's offer is nowhere near
the scale of the task
and of course the biggest challenge this
country is the climate emergency
the chancellor just talked up his green
credentials
but his budget stops way short of what
was needed
or what's happening in other countries
this budget
should have included a major green
stimulus bringing forward billions of
pounds of investment to create new jobs
a new green infrastructure instead
instead the government is trying to
build a new coal mine
which we now learn might not even work
for british steel
if anything sums up this government's
commitment
to a green recovery and jobs of the
future it's building a coal mine
we can't even use
if the government was serious about
tackling insecurity
and that those most at risk from covid
this budget would have fixed the broken
system of statutory sick pay
and at the very least fill the glaring
holes in isolation payments
this isn't difficult to fix the
government should just make the 500
pound
isolation payment available to everyone
who needs it
that would be money well spent and a
year into the pandemic
it's a disgrace that it's not
if the government was serious about
fixing the broken housing market
it would have announced plans for a new
generation of genuinely affordable
council houses
instead 230 council homes
230 000 council homes have been lost
since 2010
yet the chancellor focused today on
returning
to subsidizing 95 of mortgages
now i know what you're thinking i've
heard that somewhere before
i've heard that somewhere before maybe
it was because the prime minister
announced it five months ago in his
conference
speech no i don't think anybody heard
that
i remember now i remember now it's what
osborne and cameron came up with in
2013.
and what did that do what did that do
it fueled a housing bubble it pushed up
prices and made owning a home more
difficult
so much for generation by i've been
saying for weeks that this budget will
go
back i didn't expect the chancellor to
lift a failed policy from eight years
ago
this budget fell far short of the
transformative change we needed to turbo
charge our recovery
for the decades to come there was no
credible plan to ease the burden of debt
hanging over
so many businesses this is estimated at
70 billion pounds
this budget asks businesses to start
paying that money back
whether they're profitable or not
that affects millions of businesses
it will hold back growth because
businesses will have to pay back money
they never wanted to borrow
instead of being able to invest in their
futures and create jobs in their local
areas it's both unfair
and economically illiterate
this budget also fell far short of what
was needed
to suppel to support the self-employed
and freelancers
unless of course you're one of the
chancellor's photographers
after a year of inaction after a year of
inaction
we'll look at the details of what the
chancellor announced
but it certainly looks like from the
figure of 600 000 that he mentioned
that millions will still be left out in
the cold
the chancellor's one normally long-term
policy was his
references to leveling up
but what does that actually look like
it's not the transformative shift in
power wealth and resources we need
to rebalance our economy it's not the
bold long-term plan we need to upskill
our economy
to tackle educational attainment or to
raise life expectancy
it certainly isn't a plan to focus
government resources on preventative
services
and early years for the chancellor
leveling up seems to mean moving some
parts of the treasury
to darlington creating a few
free ports and re-announcing funding
that isn't leveling up it's giving up
and instead instead of putting blind
faith in freeports
the chancellor would be better served
making sure that
government's brexit deal actually works
for britain's manufacturers who now face
more red tape
when they were promised less for our
financial services
still waiting for the chancellor to make
good on his promises
for the small businesses and fishing
communities whose goods and produce
are now left unsold in warehouses and
for our artists and performers
who just want to be able to tour
turning to other parts of the statement
we'll wait for the detail about the
so-called super deduction
but it's unlikely to make up for the 10
years
when the levels of private investment
growth have trailed
so many other countries of course we
welcome the creation of the national
infrastructure bank
something we've called for for years
although it'd be better if the
government hadn't sold off the green
investment bank
in the first place
we also welcome the introduction of
green saving bonds
i have to say what a good idea it is to
introduce a new set of recovery bombs
the trouble is that the scale of what
the chancellor announced today is
nowhere near ambitious enough
and the long overdue commitments to
extend furlough
business rate relief and the v80 cut on
hospitality
are welcome but there is no excuse
for holding the announcement of this
support back until today
and of course we'll look at the detail
but madam deputy speaker there are very
few silver linings in this budget
the imf and the oecd have said now isn't
the time for tax rises
we're in the middle of a once in 300
year crisis
our economy is still shut our businesses
are on life support so it's right that
corporation tax isn't rising
this year or next of course in the long
run
corporation tax should go up the
decade-long
corporation tax experiment by this
government
has failed but no taxes should have been
raised in the teeth of this economic
crisis
so it's ex so it's extraordinary that
the
chancellor is plowing ahead with a two
billion pound
council tax rise affecting households
across the country so why is he doing
that
why is he doing that when every
economist would tell him not to do it
perhaps we find the answer in this
week's sunday times
rishi's argument let's do all this now
far away from the election as possible
or the telegraph on the 27th of january
raising taxes now means that they can be
reduced ahead of the next election
soon act tells mps or the mail
in september soon act to hike taxes
and lower than before the election
let me be crystal clear the proper basis
for making tax decisions is the economic
cycle
not the electoral cycle madam deputy
speaker
behind the spin the videos and the photo
ops
we all know the chancellor doesn't
believe in an active and
enterprising government we know
we know he's itching to get back to his
free market principles
and to pull away support as quickly as
he can one day these restrictions will
end
one day we'll all be able to take our
masks off and say will the chancellor
and then you'll see who he really is and
this budget
sets it up perfectly because this is a
budget
that didn't even attempt to rebuild the
foundations of our economy
or to secure the country's long-term
prosperity
instead it did the job the chancellor
always intended
a quick fix papering over the cracks
the party opposite spent a decade
weakening the foundations of our economy
now they pretend they can rebuild it but
the truth is
they won't confront what went wrong in
the past and they have no plan
for the future thank you madam deputy
speaker
thank you we now go by video